the most story division in sports and
it's what could go wrong whoops you
extended the wrong guy now it's ours for
the taking
what could go wrong just win a games you
don't know how good you have it got a
clear path what could go wrong
through your game three yard gain grab
it boys hey it's just me Josh McCown
left I think I'm your punter now I
should lose tonight as in the wild-card
I'm open I'm not open that catch number
one offense in every metric the points
what could go let's settle for that
Jason no hey Lincoln Riley I'll give you
a billion dollars say yes to me for 10
years hey Doc you said he just has to
lose to LSU first ha ha we need help and
I know just the guy Santa tell the
battery
break right thank God somebody say
spoiler go for it what he said yes go
great job everyone
can't believe we lost to one of them it
can't all be great rivalries like us Tom
if you want the NFC East to be good
again please subscribe below so the NFL
will rename the LA Rams to the Delaware
clamps Oh Delaware we raise our cup from
our sandy beach chair
we proudly L to our folks one two three
clever